(crew applauds)
First up to watch:
this weekend, "The Crown" Season 4!
The fourth season drops on Netflix Sunday,
and it is such a great window into the royal family.
Plus, we're interviewing Emma Corrin
who plays Princess Diana, and Josh O'Connor
who plays Prince Charles.
By the way, I got to meet Princess Diana when I was little,
I did. It was like, I'll never forget it.
When you're a little girl meeting a real life princess,
and her, oh my goodness.
I can't wait to watch this season.
I'm very excited to speak with them.
Okay!
(British accent) Watch "The Crown" this weekend.
(crew laughs)
But if you're headed outdoors
this weekend, then check out this Style Alert!
(crew cheers)
(alarm blares)
To buy: Sorel Boots.
We saw these boots on Katie Holmes,
and the Sorel Boot just got the Oprah seal of approval,
making her Favorite Things List for 2020.
I love my Sorels, comfy, rugged, and guess what?
If a surprise mountain crops up between me and the CVS,
I'm ready for that surprise mountain.
(crew laughs)
(crew cheers)
And if your weekend could benefit from a glimpse
of a chic Shih Tzu,
listen, you have got to
follow this account.
(crew laughs)
I am not kidding.
Jess Rona Grooming, I literally am so obsessed.
Ember, one of our producers, one of my producers,
one of my partners, she turned me on
to this Instagram account and she changed my life.
Trust me, yours is about to get changed, too.
Okay, now I am so excited, 'cause she's also
coming on the show soon, too, but I'm freaking out.
(crew cheers)
I, just, just get into it.
Trust me. Hopefully, you'll be as happy as I was.
I bet you will.
Okay, my next pick has the simple motto,
"Stay at home and make something."
To inspire: A Beautiful Mess on Instagram.
It's craft week, so we're spotlighting
one of the original DIY lifestyle blogs.
These two sisters serve up gorgeous shots of everything,
from recipes and paper crafts, home makeovers, and more.
A Beautiful Mess is also what I consider
the Drew's News desk.
(crew cheers)
That's right, I'm a mess.
What can I say?
Next step, to craft: Etsy store create the culture
offers DIY embroidery kits where you can hand stitch
really cool designs like these,
into shirts or pillows or frames.
We actually have one right here in my hand, and I love this.
This is like, super cool.
So you get the kit and the ring.
I'm gonna do this this weekend.
Also, I always want it to like, come like this.
I need the whole thing to be inspired and motivated.
So, if podcasts are more your tune,
here's something to listen to,
"The Science of Happiness" Podcast, produced by scientists
at UC Berkeley's Greater Good Science Center.
This series covers everything
from how gratitude affects your brain,
my brain should be pretty happy,
I feel like I'm a grateful person.
(crew laughs)
I don't know
if you could tell.
And how your brain is also affected
by small acts of kindness,
and it produces all this different type of chemistry.
Which is great, because today is World Kindness Day.
So, be kind to the world and kind to yourselves,
if you can at the same time.
(crew cheers)
Yeah, that's the one I have a problem with, me.
And finally, an entry from the Little Yellow Book.
That's right, it's a list of my personal picks
updated every week on our site.
I labor over this. I love this list.
It's very important to me.
And this week, we're excited
because Flower Beauty bluelight glasses.
Yeah, it's on, they're back.
(crew oohing)
We have new styles.
And today, these peeper protectors launch at Walmart,
and they come in six different styles.
Here's one,
here's two.
By the way, we make these really big ones now.
And I just have to say, I really, really love them,
because you know what?
Bigger sometimes is really fun
when you're looking at big screens or little screens,
or you're like this (laughing)
all day long, alright?
(crew laughs)
For more picks on Drew's Little Yellow Book,
always feels weird to say my name,
check it out now on our website.
(crew cheers)
And that was The Weekender!
(upbeat music)